we last spoke to tim when
we were in person in nashville for an
amazing
nfl draft that was remarkable
that week and uh the grammy
award-winning recording artist with a
new album here on earth which
is available everywhere right now as it
was released last week is back here on
the rich eisen show how are you tim
i'm doing well how are you man i'm
telling you i'm not just saying that
because you were on the phone i have
said it with you not being on the phone
that week in nashville was amazing
and if the draft is in fact going to be
like the super bowl where you have
certain cities like new orleans and
south florida
now maybe los angeles on a rotation that
every now and then they've got to get it
nashville if the draft is like that has
to get it every now and then
i agree i think it was it was so much
fun you know it
i remember watching the draft in philly
i think it was
maybe two years before that yep and uh
i called my manager right away says look
we have to get get everybody on the
phone and try to get this thing to
nashville because
i think we could do it really do it well
with some music and do it downtown and
boy it really turned out great it was um
it was fun to be involved with it from
the beginning and and work on getting it
there and
and just to see how well it turned out
and how well the city handled it it was
it was it was pretty
it was pretty spectacular we i tell you
that was one of the funnest concerts
i've ever had in my life
out there doing that i wonder what it
was like because i know we're
from my position because you know that
was the if i'm not mistaken because it
feels like it's
a million years ago not just a year and
a half but uh i think it was the friday
night
of the draft the second night of the
draft where
as soon as it was over you came out and
you performed
yeah and uh i was sitting
on my set you know off to the side of
the stage and just i couldn't see
all the way um down broadway i couldn't
see the entire what was it like from
your perspective
it was incredible because it was just i
mean a sea of people that were just
completely packed in
and i mean all the you know all of them
broadway as you know has has all those
bars and
all the neon lights and and neon signs
and all the balconies and everything
along the road and they were just
completely packed and full of people
all the way up to bridgestone arena
which is which is way up broadway
and i mean it was it was pretty
spectacular i mean
and and i had we the band and i both
when we came out
we had so much energy and we were so
proud of our city and proud of
the way everybody handled it and uh it
was just
we were proud to be a part of it you
know because we're all huge
of course huge football fans and and to
be a part of it and be asked to
go out there and do a show and do it in
our hometown and do it under those
circumstances and
and that many people to turn out it was
it was um
it was pretty cool like you say i hope
hope we can do it again
i i i talked to miss mr goodell
yesterday i said well now next we have
to get the super bowl in nashville
what'd he say he said well we'll we'll
have to see about that
well i'll tell you what tim uh nashville
almost made it to the super bowl
uh exactly right the other way around
almost actually happened that
oh my gosh derek henry uh
just watching him run is truly one of
the most remarkable things what was that
watching that run for the titans like
for you and uh your wife and everybody
tim
it was incredible i mean he's a beast
you know and it just uh
it's you know to to be a national you
know faith moved to nashville in 1987
i moved to nashville in 1989 and it was
still pretty much a small town
and when when it just started it's just
been growing exponentially
you know ever since and and then to have
a football team and have a hockey team
i mean it's just it's incredible to see
how well they they've both done and and
how big the fan base has grown and how
supportive our community is
of those franchises so i i just think
it's pretty
pretty incredible to watch and to be a
part of and and
to say that you know we have we have
teams that are competitive
and and and and have players that are
spectacular to watch and
and you know there's always a shot and
that's a pretty good feeling
when when you're when you have a team in
your hometown it's like that tim mcgraw
here on the rich eyes and show new album
here on earth which we'll talk about
in a second i don't know if we mentioned
to you when we did
see you that friday of the draft that uh
the rich eisen show crew including me
we went karaoke oh boy a couple nights
before where did we go chris we went to
santa's pub
santa's pub uh yeah
you know your reaction being oh boy um
well i'm just curious of how it went
well um we were great tim i mean
hold on a second so you did not hear how
well i mean i have a certain timber if i
may
um in my voice that uh sinatra is my
bailiwick oh there you go okay and
that's tall cotton right there
yes it is uh but i i i mean i wouldn't
compare myself to sinatra under any
circumstances
well i don't i could i'm i'm i
am i comparing myself to him i could i
mean
i just kind of did uh my version of
that's life i would put up against
anybody's oh i have to hear it then i
have to hear it
well maybe there's you know in this day
and age
you know everything's recorded
someone has it somewhere oh we've got
the video
somewhere it is actually on the phone of
myself
this is the problem of having a social
media uh coordinator who's excellent he
actually has it the problem is we don't
have the rights to play it and i don't
want to bankrupt our entire
budget for this uh for this moment in
the instagram
it could mean it's potential i want to
go up against the sinatra state
but all i'm saying is it's not just for
me tim
uh the song it's also the way it i
end and um when i when i
sing uh my way oh boy
i i do that's life it's a crowd pleaser
and then my way what i do is at the end
you know i took the blows i did it my
way and i
nail it and take the microphone
and throw it on the floor and walk out
like literally walk out but then you
know at the end
sinatra goes low and ends it very
you know calmly i come back in and
finish the song
i'm a showman is basically what i'm
saying
that's what you have you have to have a
good beginning a high point in the
middle
and a great ending you know all the
stuff that happens in between
trust me i have trouble staying on pitch
all the way through a song so
so if you could just start well hit the
high point in the middle and end well
then you're doing what you're doing
pretty damn good thank you
see i knew i was on to something and now
i've gotten tim mcgraw to actually
approve
my my showmanship tell me about this
album it's your 16th studio album tim
here on earth and it's your first solo
album in five years a hell of
a cover that we're showing right here
from big machine records i give you the
floor on this
yeah you know it's uh thank you it's
been a project we've been working on for
two and a half years or so something
like that we started working on you know
i had
faith and i did our soul-to-soul tour
for a couple of years
and we also recorded our very first
duets album during that time
and i started recording this album
toward the end
of our last leg of the soul to soul tour
for a couple of reasons i started
finding some songs that were starting to
form sort of a narrative for me what i
wanted to do
a big picture of life that dove you know
sort of a 30 000 foot view of life and
then
that dove down every now and then into
some really intimate moments about
relationships and what goes on in your
head what goes on in your heart
during relationships and but the second
reason is because i found through the
years
that every time i spend a lot of time
working with my wife
because she's in my opinion one of the
greatest singers
on the planet it it makes me better
because
i'm sort of like a nascar trying to keep
up with an indy car when i'm
on stage with her and if i don't if i
don't stay
pretty close to pitch and pretty close
on my game and try to keep
and keep up with her i get that look
across stages oh you don't want that
like sun
we're going to have words after this
show so i'll try my best not to get that
look but i
but really i always find that i'm way
better voice than i
typically you know after i've worked
with her so i wanted to take advantage
of that while we were still working
together to start an
album and it really is you know
after 16 albums it really is
probably my favorite piece of work that
i've done my entire career i think it's
my
favorite collection of songs we really
took we recorded it all on you know the
old way the analog way and then
transferred it over to digital so it's
got a really unique warmth to it
so it's um it's something that has a
really special
feel to it to me and again it's it's uh
where all
albums are can be uh acquired it's every
available everywhere
right now what about um you know post
pandemic obviously
about acting sir um about you
getting it back in front of uh and
getting on a silver screen
is there anything from your acting
career that you're particularly proud of
oh gosh right here you know i've tried
tried to throughout my career i mean i
don't you know i haven't done
i've done i guess 10 films or so but um
you know it's hard for me because
to find something that you like that's
that that
narratively you like and then to find
something that's being done or the time
that you have to work
and finding something that they actually
want you for all three of those things
have to come together so it's tough to
find projects
but gosh i'll have to go back to you
know one of my favorites friday night
lights
oh yeah i still love that movie and
it was really my first sort of big movie
i did had done flickr right before that
and then i'd done a movie called black
cloud was really my first thing but
friday nights was really the first one
that
i really really got a chance to to
play a character that that i could
identify with you know
growing up in louisiana and growing up
playing football and
baseball and basketball you know that
guy was a combination of a lot of guys
that i saw and knew
playing ball and and uh it was something
i could really relate to and then
working with pete berg and
garrett headland who's still a great
friend of mine and billy bob thornton
he's still a great friend of mine i mean
i was just thrown into the middle of a
a lot of great actors who and it's like
playing tennis or something with some
you know you play to the level of the
people that you're that you're playing
playing with and and i was lucky and
have been lucky throughout my career
to to be able to be on screen with some
really
great actors who have always learned
yeah we've had billy bob on this show
and
i i love him he's great and he didn't he
have some baseball in him like he he had
some
he he had cardinals he's well cardinal's
friend but i think he tried
he tried to he he was on pace to try and
become a major leaguer but he got hurt
or something like that i believe he was
a pitcher right i'm not mistaken yeah i
think he had a pretty good little career
going
right i think he'd make the right choice
well when you got oscar on your shelf
that kind of helps
and you know obviously i think you did
too i tell you what though if you if you
look back
i mean there's on on the dvd when when
trying lights come out
there was some um extra stuff on there
like
you know in between scenes and us
talking and playing around there was a
scene where
we had had some ball players who were
part of the part of the cast who were
playing ball when during the football
scenes
and i had cowboy boots on and billy bob
and i went was
going to be quarterback and i was going
to be wide receiver and
i did a fly pattern against one of the
cornerbacks who was a real ball player
that was out there
and billy bob hit me at about a 40-yard
pass without one-handed caught you gotta
go back and check that out
because i beat the kid who was the
player
in cleats and pads and i had cowboy
boots on and i beat him and made
made the catch did you high step in the
cowboy boots too why didn't i step i was
just i was out of breath but
[Laughter]
well again speaking of out of breath my
performance of uh of
sinatra we're going to put on my
instagram stories we're going to tag you
at the tim mcgraw check it out and uh
you know
uh if you want to respond in any way
shape or form about a
um a critique i'm i'm wide open i just
want to get better
i just want to get better i'll respond
for sure sounds good
tim thanks again always enjoy our chats
um and uh congrats on the new album
thank you man it's good to talk to you
right back at you at the the tim mcgraw
on twitter and instagram and check out
here on earth
where all music can be acquired
available everywhere
now you like that video of course you
did check out more right here